not Easter Namibia most people lived
from farming Raymond kitten Baker grows
corn like many farmers here in the
region but he has a constant job on his
hands protecting his crops from hungry
neighbors we think you don't wanna TV
there were seven elephants as soon as we
heard them we ran out to drive him away
you know but the elephants aren't afraid
of us so they just stay put they
destroyed the fields and suddenly our
livelihood was gone we fear for our
lives but elephants and people do
largely get along here conservationists
and local authorities have set up
protected corridors allowing the
elephants to roam along age-old routes
these trails are patrolled regularly to
preempt possible problems such as
elephants crossing busy roads yeah we
are standing on a migratory route that
is coming from butanna to Angola to
Zambia and Angola unfortunately
dispatches the trances am busy highway
where it could be danger to wildlife
such as elephant and also people the
project is part of the Cahuenga Zambezi
Park it covers territory in Botswana
Namibia Zambia Angola and simba buey the
park is successful because the local
people profit from the elephants they
have even set up conservation areas
outside the park so they can earn money
as we hear from chief joseph my uni the
community leader room where you're
protecting the elephants has created
jobs for the young people in our
community we also get a good income from
tourism from lodges and campsites then
we also have trophy hunting in our area
funding firms get licenses which also
bring us a lot of money when you too
warm around hunting and tourism provide
the main sources of income lodge owner
johann marx says that means local people
really value the animals over a long
period of time they can receive
financial benefit from the animals
instead of poaching them
as a result the elephants are free to
roam almost as they please even if that
does mean crossing the odd road or other
man-made obstacles